Il est jusqu'à 17 % dans les
intentions de vote. Donc voici
ce que ça donne avec notre
collègue à Paris, Raphaël
Bouvier au clair.
Officiellement le public vient
assister à un événement
de promotion littéraire.
Mais dès que l'auteur arrive,
on comprend rapidement
qu'il s'agit d'un rassemblement
politique.
Une salle comble pour entendre
Eric Zemmour, polémiste
d'extrême-droite et possible
candidat à l'élection
présidentielle.
- Ce n'est pas un politicien...
comme les autres.
- C'est quelqu'un qui sait
résister, parfois seul contre
tous; contre des pensées
de gauche à laquelle la droite
est traditionnellement soumise.
(applaudissements et slogan)
Journaliste, auteur,
commentateur, Éric Zemmour,
qui promet de rendre sa grandeur
à la France, se démarque depuis
des années par ses positions
controversées.
L'ancien éditorialiste du Figaro
se dit philosophiquement en
accord avec la peine de mort,
critique le féminisme; mais
sa grande préoccupation
est surtout l'immigration.
Condamné par la justice par
le passé pour incitation
à la haine, il n'hésite pas
à parler de grand remplacement
par les musulmans et du besoin
d'assimiler les nouveaux
arrivants.
ÉRIC ZEMMOUR,
polémiste
- Moi, j'essaie d'arrêter ce...
cette invasion migratoire
et ce basculement
civilisationnel.
- Il n'est pas officiellement
déclaré, et pourtant, Éric
Zemmour reçoit l'attention
médiatique d'un véritable
candidat. Les sondeurs mesurent
ses appuis. À la télévision et
dans les journaux, on rapporte
presque tout ce qu'il dit.
BENJAMIN TAINTURIER, doctorant
Médialab de SciencesPo
- Il y a tout un tas de façon
de parler de lui. Est-ce qu'on
fait du fact checking
systématique sur toutes
ces erreurs historiques?
Et il y en a... il y en a
beaucoup à relever, surtout
ses approximations. On peut,
mais ça nous condamne à faire
cinq à dix par jour sur lui.
- Cet expert des médias et
de la droite radicale revient
sur un exemple qui a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre cette semaine.
- Reculez, reculez.
- En visitant un salon de
sécurité, Éric Zemmour a pointé
une arme vers des journalistes
affirmant faire une blague.
Un geste qui a soulevé un tollé.
CLÉMENT BEAUNE, secrétaire
d'État Affaires européennes
- Les idées, les provocations
qui sont les siennes
aujourd'hui, moi, je
les combats radicalement!
- Si vous ne savez pas
la différence entre l'humour,
la blague et le sérieux,
c'est que vous êtes un imbécile.
- Provoquer le dégoût,
la détestation, soit en...
avec les petites phrases de
Donald Trump qu'on connaît très,
très bien. Soit en braquant
une arme vers les journalistes
de façon complètement grotesque
parce que assumé. Ça, ça pouvait
paradoxalement vous amener
du crédit et vous amener
des soutiens.
- Au-delà des critiques,
la présence d'Éric Zemmour sur
la scène publique place certains
politiciens sur la défensive,
comme Marine Le Pen que
le polémiste talonne maintenant
dans les sondages.
MARINE LE PEN, candidate
présidentielle France, RN
- C'est peut-être moins sexy
pour les journalistes, mais
je crois que c'est ce
qu'attendent en l'occurrence
les Français : de la pugnacité,
du travail, du sérieux,
du long terme.
- Surtout que parmi
les sympathisants du polémiste,
certains accusent Marine Le Pen
et son parti, de s'être trop
recentrés, d'avoir fait trop
de compromis.
- Le rassemblement national
s'est beaucoup décrédibilisé
au cours des dernières années
avec un discours fluctuant.
- Éric Zemmour fait tout de même
face à son lot de difficultés.
Sans parti, atteindre
la présidence demeure
un grand défi. Mais il se targue
déjà d'une première victoire :
Avoir forcé les autres candidats
à se prononcer sur certains
items prioritaires comme
l'immigration et la sécurité.
- En tous cas, vous avez vu
qu'ils s'imposent à ma grande
joie. J'ai tout fait pour.
Ils s'imposent dans cette
première partie de campagne.
- Sans même qu'on sache
s'il sera du scrutin dans six
mois, le polémiste a déjà réussi
à bousculer l'échiquier
politique français.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier Auclair,
Radio-Canada, à Versa